[Music]
prepare for a film so terrified they
will convince an entire generation of
kids not to be astronauts
gravity you've seen it in pulse-pounding
IMAX 3d now experience the massive
letdown when you watch it on your crappy
home television or iPad or phone
oh man that's depressing
please don't watch this movie on your
phone strap in for an epic visual
experience director Alfonso Kuran spent
four and a half years meticulously
crafting beautiful do you think but the
dialogue not so much tell me about the
hairy guy huh tell me what happened what
happened to the hairy guy blast off with
the hottest astronauts ever Ryan stone
who really shouldn't be allowed in space
Matt George Clooney Kowalski a George
Clooney ish pilot with the charm of
George Clooney I know you never realized
how devastatingly good-looking I am
you're attracted to me and cherif who's
only there for five minutes before his
face gets hole punched here with their
simple repair mission literally spirals
out of control you'll be on the edge of
your seat trying to hold in your barf
I hear it close my eyes okay get ready
for 90 minutes of bumping into stuff and
[Music]
fighting against impossible odds to grab
on to stuff almost stretch almost got it
just a little more there you go
drift to the terrifying silence of outer
space where the only sound you can hear
is Sandra Bullock explaining the plot 7
minutes to get out of here clear skies
with a Chance of satellite debris visit
the journey station
Shia LaBeouf a
and gasping for air
so right along for a thrilling adventure
that will have audiences cheering when
our hero finally makes it back to earth
alive even though he lost the space
shuttle and the International Space
Station and the Chinese space station
and the Hubble telescope and Facebook
half a North America just lost their
Facebook and made so much debris you
won't be able to leave the earth for
hundreds of years
guess we won't be going to Mars any time
soon starring incompetent Ripley
Buzz Lightyear Gus fring countdowns
timers alarms and wall-e gravity god
that tracking shot is the coolest thing
I've ever seen
that's not a joke I just want to make
sure that was on record be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers
deepest bluest my hat is like a shark's
fin I am tired of these monkey fighting
snakes on this Monday to Friday plain
straight cash PO me sit your five dollar
ass down before I make change get over
here
I'm doing stuff Laurie bags